How's this for sun and fun?
At least 15,000 sharks are swimming off the South Florida coast,...
...just in time for the annual influx of spring breakers.
The huge migration of blacktip and spinner sharks is happening later this year,...
...putting the sharks at odds with the vacationing crowds.
Researchers estimate that tourists brave enough to swim in the waters near the migration...
...are on average just 60 feet away from travelling sharks.
Some beaches are on high alert, but of course the risk remains low.
Blacktip and spinner sharks only account for about 25% of annual attacks on Florida...
...and just 26 attacks were recorded there last year, none of them fatal.
Still, you can imagine some revelers aren't quite convinced...
...that it's safe to go back in the water.